Neil Baldwin would you go back and tell
the story that you tell at the end of
the book about meeting the son of Thomas
Alva Edison there his death Theodore yes
yes indeed well no one was allowed to
come in from the outside world
Theodore Edison was in his 90s this was
just a couple of years ago and I was
sort of halfway through the book and I'm
so concerned in all of my biographies
I've been very concerned about touching
directly with the family of the subject
and so I had worked my way in I had met
the nephews and some of the cousins and
ingratiate myself and finally was given
permission to enter the inner sanctum
and go up to his home in West Orange he
lived in Llewellyn Park which is a very
exclusive suburb of West Orange New
Jersey and the nurse let me in to this
very old house sick very very secluded
way off the beaten track I never would
have found it if I hadn't gotten
directions and Theodore Edison was lying
in a hospital bed
the shades were drawn it was very dark
and I remember it was one of those beds
with the railings on either side and he
was lying there next to his right hand
was a telephone that you you know it was
one of those cradle phones with the very
black cradle phones with the dials not
like something out of the 1930s so
they're very frayed cord you know and
the nurse was there and she introduced
me to him mr. Edison his hands were sort
of he had very bad arthritis his hands
were sort of clenched on his chest and
he could hardly speak his in the last
stages of Parkinson's disease but he
knew who I was he knew why I was there
and he had read my book on William
Carlos Williams which really astonished
me that he had actually he knew of that
book and I started chatting with him I
asked him about one of the major things
in the book is the celebration of the
4th of July which was a
big holiday in the Edison family and how
Thomas Edison used to make his own
fireworks construct his own fireworks
and have the kids run barefoot on the
lawn and he would throw firecrackers at
their feet they would jump up and down
then they would eat watermelon and have
a grand old time and and Theodore was
able to to conjure up this image of a
bygone American time as if it were
yesterday even though he was laboring
very very deeply with the problems of
Parkinson's disease then we talked a
little bit about the the radio you know
Edison was concerned that the radio was
just a quote unquote a fad and he was
reluctant to enter into the technology
but he let his sons Charles and Theodore
begin to manufacture radios in the 1920s
so we talked a little bit about that
then his wife came in and she was in a
wheelchair she sort of interrupted the
conversation and asked me what I was
doing there was a very very protective
woman and we talked with her for a while
the impression was of a person with an
ember of thought in his mind even though
his body was very very infirm
I felt this was a person with life in
his brain
but dying out slowly and three or four
months later he died but I I call him
the last Edison because none of Thomas
Edison's male children had offsprings so
in fact Theodore was the last person
with the name surname Edison left and
now he's gone Thomas Edison made what
wouldn't he invent oh heavens well since
this is only an hour program well he's
known for a thousand over a thousand
patents the phonograph
that variant varying permutations of the
telegraph the electric pen the concrete
house the storage battery the phonograph
cylinder the disk record all sorts of
dynamos every component of an electrical
system I think that one of the points I
try to get into in the book is it isn't
just these free-standing inventions that
we should think of when we think of it
and we should think of systems of
inventions and the light bulb which is
the most familiar to all of us the one
that we grow up learning about really is
one component of an entire system of
delivering electric power to domestic
and corporate settings so that you have
to think of the the dynamo that
generates the electricity the wire that
goes under the streets the wire that
goes from the streets to the actual
apartment or factory the fuses the the
measuring system for the the meters the
filaments of the bulb in addition to the
bulb itself at the very end the sort of
end product and Edison actually spoke
about his pride in the entire system
that he created that was his real in his
mind that was the invention rather than
just the the bulb or the lamp as it was
known in those days it wasn't called the
ball pens on the lamp actually how long
did he live let's see 1847 to 1931 so
that's 84 years and that's why actually
inventing the century was a concept that
I thought very carefully about because I
feel he represents the era and is a
representation of the era at the same
time he exemplifies the century that the
waning of one ERA and the beginning of
another as well as
being a major prototype of the time he
defines the time and the designs define
him Oh picture that we've been showing
from the cover was what age was he that
would be probably about 4045 years old
when he was really reaching the the
apotheosis of his career I mean he was a
very very entrepreneurial and very
ambitious person and I wouldn't say he
had a goal to be a millionaire by the
time he was 40 but he was a millionaire
by the time it was 40 years old where
was he born he was born in Milan Ohio
which is a little town is still very
much the same way it was in 1840s it's
about 60 miles west of Cleveland and his
forebears actually were Canadian his
father came over from the north country
and set up a single shop there and in
Milan Ohio and Edison was actually one
of seven children and he was born there
his mother his mother's forebears fought
in the Revolutionary War American
Revolution and so there was a kind of a
strong patriotic strain to his
background
combined with the the intrepid nature of
the northern Canadian blue bloods blue
noses as they were called because
they're the cold weather where'd he get
the name Thomas Alba
well actually Alva was named after
captain Alva Bradley who was a steamship
captain who helped the family when they
were coming in from Canada helped them
bring their goods in their provisions
over to Milan and he was a very close
friend of the Edison family you say that
in the early days he called him you want
to be called al little al yes well he
liked to be called al when he was little
boy very young and then he graduated to
Tom as a teenager and later on in life
even the people who knew him always
referred to him as mr. Edison as a
matter of fact in the travels I've been
doing and meeting with some of the
people and especially in Florida where
Edison had a winter home there are still
people there who knew him when they were
children and their parents knew him and
they still refer to him as mr. Edison as
a kind of a reverential feeling there
how long did he live in Milan Ohio well
he lived there till he was early
childhood a menace to Port Huron
Michigan when he was about 8 years old
hello and he stood there and he lived
there he worked on the railroad he
worked for the the Grand Trunk railroad
which was a line that ran down to
Detroit from Port Huron and back and
that was when he began publishing his
own newspaper on the train typesetting
it and by hand publishing it and selling
it to all the people on the train and he
also ran a he had a he worked on his
father's truck farm growing vegetables
and so those on the train also it was
extremely adept for a teenager and he
learned telegraphy at the train station
nearby in Mount Clemens Michigan
gradually expanded his universe during
the Civil War he was an itinerant
telegrapher throughout the Midwest
living in various towns and working part
time learning the craft of of telegraphy
which was very common profession for
young men of that period around the
Civil War time and he moved to Boston
when he was about 20 20 years old and
then New York and then Newark Menlo Park
and the rest of his life in New Jersey
as which is where most people you know
think of him as being a New Jersey ID
but in fact
he had his formative years in the
Midwest what time back in those years
after the Civil War what about when did
electricity and the telephone and
refrigeration and light bulbs I know
that he's all a part of this because
when did the first part of that that
those things come into being and and you
know like when did the Telegraph start
being used
well telegraphy was a very nascent
industry that grew up sort of in tandem
with the railroad you have to see them
as sort of brothers in technology if you
will that is to say that telegraphy sort
of progressed in complexity in the 1850s
1860s I always like to say that Edison
grew up with the railroad he actually
was born at a time when canals were the
major infrastructure system that was
used for commerce that you could you
could travel through the waterways
actually from the Midwest all the way to
New York through the canals the Great
Lakes and so forth
but with the rise of the railroad that
the change in the way in which Goods and
information were transported
necessitated an upgrade in the
accompanying technology that's sort of
not the way I see it anyway so I think
that what Edison Edison that's what I
mean by the fact that he defined his era
and was defined by his era he was had
his ear to the ground in a sense of what
was required by this growing nation and
he understood the first the first sort
of telegraphy that he got into the first
sort of communication that he got into
after the railroad was between
businesses a very rudimentary kind of I
guess you would call it a local area
network now is what the way I analogize
it is the land of today really because
Edison saw that the best way to grow a
an industry was in concentric circles so
he started by marketing these
telegraphic services to related
businesses in a community
and I think he really had a sense of the
pulse of the need of corporate America
because you have to remember this is you
know a late 1860's early 1870s we're
talking about and I you know he had
always had one eye on the future when he
was developing his inventions Milan Ohio
Port Huron Michigan right Boston right
about how old was he when he got to
Boston
let's see that would be late 1860's so
early 20s he married yet no actually
what happened was he moved to the opened
his own shop right outside of Newark New
Jersey this would be about 1870 or there
abouts he was 23 24 years old and that
was where he met his first wife her name
was Mary Stillwell and her family was
from the Newark area Newark New Jersey
and she was working for him as a in a
clerical capacity and she was a very
attractive very young blonde gray eyed a
woman her father was a Sawyer a merchant
and so they were married at Christmas of
1871 and they had three children what
were the names Tom jr. of course William
and Marian how long were they married
well she bore him these three children
over 13 years during the course of which
as I as I said earlier this was the
period when Edison was building his
empire he was proud of the fact that
certain times of the year he was away
from the home for a hundred nights in a
row a hundred nights in a row working in
the lab and his notebooks which I
studied very carefully because I think
they are the true chronology of his
career he left over 3,000 laboratory
notebooks behind where are they
those are housed in the Edison
Historic Site in West Orange New Jersey
that's where the major Aniston archive
is located the actual notebook yes they
are and you read the notebooks not at
Michael for homework well I wanted to
get I read them in both ways actually
now that you mentioned I wanted to see I
I have a background in studying
manuscripts as a kind of way to build my
biographies and I decided to approach
these notebooks and as almost a
free-standing literary genre in and of
themselves because Edison says in one of
the first notebooks I am going to make a
full record of my career and so I said
to myself well knowing his his the
importance of them from a documentation
point of view knowing that if you're
going to create a patent you have to
keep a record of the time the place the
date of the invention you have to keep a
record of who was working on it with you
you have to have a witness for the
invention you have to have the most
assiduous documentation when you're
trying to create a patent for you know
for the consumer industry so on that
level the notebooks are important
because they are Edison's chronology of
his work but they also contain ideas and
half-formed thoughts and sketches and
perceptions for other works and other
creations that he had thought of that
did not become fully realized as you
know in the marketplace and that's where
you get the vision of Thomas Edison's
imagination that's where you get the
vision of him as a as a introspective
creative person he writes down all the
things of all the books he's right he's
reading he writes down the names of
people that he meets who give him ideas
he writes down
chemicals that he wants to purchase
tools that he wants to purchase you get
some sense of what direction he's going
in his research I mean
these are really the the chronicle of
his entire life and I think that it's
significant that he kept running in
these notebooks long after he was able
to visit the lab when he was sick man
when he was in bed when he couldn't lift
his head off the pillow he's still
writing in the notebooks because it's
the process that's important to him
not just the manifestation not just the
thing but the process of how you get
through an idea how you track your
thoughts and how you monitor your
thoughts how'd you get interested in him
in the first place well I my first two
subjects were William Carlos Williams
the poet and physician and probably you
could say the precursor of modern poetry
in America today and the second subject
was Man Ray who was the photographer and
painter was also a great American figure
and I viewed Man Ray as a quintessential
modernist figure and what I did was if
William Carlos Williams I was talking
about as onra and the history of a genre
and then I decided the most important
thing after that would be to try to
define a period as a whole the modern
period as a whole so Man Ray to me was
the metaphor for the modernist period in
art and then I thought well I've dealt
with two highly creative individuals and
I've explored their imaginations but I
wanted to make the point that creativity
and imagination are not the sole
province of the artist the the humanist
thinker I wanted to show that invention
which was actually defined as an art in
Edison's time it was actually called the
art of invention I wanted to show that
the inventive process the creative
process they all stem from the the the
deepest core of the imagination in a
human being and I wanted to connect all
those creative processes in the context
of an American vision and if you look at
the time frame for these three books
William Carlos Williams man right Thomas
Edison they all begin sort of in the
last vestiges of the industrial era and
the Romantic era in culture and they
pass through the Cataclysm of the wars
and they end up sort of on the threshold
of our day and so I do think they all
connect even though on first blush it is
it's hard to see the connection but I
think there is a connection where's home
for you home for me well I consider
myself a native New Yorker since on my
mother's side my I have third generation
Manhattan night and my kids were born in
New York City too
but I live in Upper Montclair New Jersey
which is right down the street from the
Edison lab so since I spent every Friday
at the Edison laboratory for four years
doing my research it was very convenient
my travel budget was was pretty well
under control why'd you pick Freddy's
well you see I have a full-time job as
the executive director of the National
Book Foundation which is the sponsor of
the National Book Awards and I run this
Foundation which has become quite a a
large enterprise the National Book Award
is a very prestigious literary prize and
so my writing has always taken place on
Fridays Saturdays Sundays and holidays
and vacations because that's really when
I take off from my full-time job so
that's why Fridays are so good because
you can work yourself into the weekend
and not interfere with your 40 hours
that you have to do other jobs how big
is the National Book Foundation well the
National Book Foundation is small and
staff we own they're only four of us but
our sculpt has become huge the
submissions by publishers to submit
titles to be nominated for National Book
Award has doubled in the past five years
and we now give three awards for
nonfiction fiction and poetry
we added poetry a couple of years or
three years ago
and we also present authors National
Book Award winners and finalists talking
about their work in communities all
across the country we work in settlement
houses museums Native American
reservations schools libraries we are
committed to taking the cachet of this
great prize and bringing it to a much
broader public and becoming known not
only for literary distinction but for
pluralism we want to show that these
great works in our tradition can be
accessible to a very very broad audience
you know I think that you know I'm
thinking a lot about the relationship of
the subjects from our biographies and my
job shall we say and I think there is
the the point is that the the American
story is a very big story and a very
varied story and since my first roots
are in literature I feel very very
deeply committed to the - to bringing a
great quality writing to a larger
audience and making it the province of
more people even though the publishing
industry is you know fundamentally an
East Coast phenomenon and then the
corporate structures are in the East
Coast but the public is very wide and
very broadly based and I think we have a
responsibility to them how long have you
run the foundation let's see the
National Book Foundation was created
about five and a half years ago by the
Board of Trustees of the then National
Book Award and I was brought on to put a
programmatic shell around the conferring
of the awards and - at the time you may
recall a literacy that the whole
literacy struggle was really coming to
the forefront with mrs. Bush and being a
great spokeswoman for that and the board
felt that there had to be a way to
construct a social mission a socially
responsible mission for the awards so
that they were not owned they were not
simply
the province of the few but that they
belong to the many that if we're going
to be a cultural player if the
foundation's going to be a cultural
player and a cultural participant then
we have to spread the word we have to
proselytize how long's the National Book
Award been around see the National Book
Awards been around since 1950 and who
won it last year the nonfiction well
that would be dr. Sherwin Nuland who
wrote the book how we died he was the
nonfiction winner over the last couple
years can you name others well of course
Annie Proulx was the fiction winner for
the shipping news about nonfiction well
Paul monette who recently passed away
wrote a book called becoming a man he
was the nonfiction winner in Orlando
Patterson who's a professor at the
Harvard wrote a book called freedom and
he was a very distinguished winner I
mean the thing is that every year the
judges change and so you have a whole
new constituency a whole new critical
opinion where does the foundation get
its money well the National Book
Foundation is a non-profit 501c3
organization and we are supported to a
tremendous degree by the publishing
industry not only in New York City but
all around the country because all the
publishers that submit to us now
including I should say more than a third
of all the members of the American
Association of University presses which
is a tremendous new growing I think
growing sector of the publishing world
the small poetry presses as well as the
big corporations in New York plus we
have wonderful funding from private
foundations the Lila Wallace reader's
digest fund and focus a month Club and
concerned individuals quick things where
were you born where was I born I was
born in New York City Manhattan
immanent yeah you're married how many
children - how old not boy and a girl 15
my son is 15 his name is Nicholas and my
daughter is Allegra she's 13 where did
you go to college I went to the
University of Rochester upstate New York
and then I did my graduate work in
poetry at SUNY Buffalo
and what did you do before you got into
the foundation well I basically spent
the last two decades in the nonprofit
sector raising money for literature I
was at the New York Public Library on
42nd Street for five years working with
Vartan Gregorian on the on the campaign
for the library to rehabilitate that
entire institution and I was running the
Annual Fund they're raising money for
operations back to the book certainly
when did Thomas Edison start to lose his
hearing see this is a story that I
thought this is a chance to set the
record straight because here you have a
person who was essentially I believe
suffered first from variable hearing
loss as a child and I think this is I
think a lot of parents who have young
children can understand this I mean ear
infections and hearing loss are very
common among little kids starting one
you know just after they're born you
have to remember this is a long long
time ago before penicillin and before
the kinds of sophisticated treatments we
have now so as a little boy Edison was
chastised by his teachers for not
listening in class daydreaming and he
really couldn't hear it wasn't that he
wasn't listening was that he couldn't
hear but the teachers chastised him in
front of the class and when he was seven
years old after only three months of
schooling his mother came in and yanked
him out of there he never went back to
school again he was home-schooled for
quite a long time and then he became
again as a consequence of his
progressively degenerative hearing he
became a very introspective child he
became a voracious reader he became
literally an autodidact who as an adult
had a standing order at brentano's
bookstore for every single new book that
came in was shipped directly to his home
so first you finally the chronic ear
infections you finally hear
laws that became as I found doing my
research
he developed an arthritic condition of
the inner ear in other words the three
the three bones that has we call him the
hammer the anvil and the stirrup which
are the three little bones that unique
that vibrate and touch each other those
three bones fused together at a certain
point probably in his 40s and 50s
because I've seen the records of his
visits to a doctor and that was the way
they described it he also had several
abscess abscess problems which had to be
lanced which were behind his right ear
especially and you see him a lot of
times in the photographs you see him
cupping this hand so a variety of era of
ear problems afflicted Thomas Edison yet
I would say he was only became totally
deaf toward the very end which
ironically or paradoxically is when he
entered the record business and started
auditioning opera singers and
instrumentalists and in those instances
he would either put his head entire head
inside the megaphone of the phonograph
stick it all the way in there turn the
volume all the way up or in one or two
instances when a pianist was auditioning
he would literally clenched his teeth
around the frame of the piano and the
vibrations has come would come through
his jaw bone and he would and and he
would sense the music in that way and
I've seen the teeth marks on this side
of the piano and Thomas Edison's home
but he signed off on every single
recording that was made for his record
company even as his hearing was
practically nil first wife died when and
why what was the disease well I think
that and again I don't like to speculate
in any of my books my I can definitely
say that Mary Stilwell was a very lonely
woman she was depressed the few letters
of hers that survived
talk about herself being alone that
Edison isn't here you know my husband is
not here I have terrible headaches she
would say my head is splitting she
became a drinker we know this from the
bills that she saved for her accounts
with the liquor store she was a big
sherry drinker
and she gained a tremendous amount of
weight toward the end she became a
compulsive eater also and some of the
pictures of her toward the end and again
we're talking about a woman in her 20s
when you compare them to her wedding
picture which is in the book they're
almost you almost can't recognize them
and I mean she was a neglected woman a
neglected woman with three little kids
and a husband who wasn't around and
asked to the actual physical reason
cause for her death I don't really know
that but she died very young and very
sadly and alone who was his second wife
the second wife our story changes a
hundred and eighty degrees because you
have to you have to put this in the
relationship in the context of a man who
has achieved a certain level and a
certain lifestyle and still quite young
and still has three little children to
take care of
I mean Edison was one of these people I
think who who had to be taken care of by
a woman and I don't think he would have
admitted that in so many words but
there's no question in my mind he met
miner Miller was a young woman who he
met through family friends in Boston
when he when Edison was recently widowed
and he was associating with some of his
bachelor friends and they were trying to
you know uh connect him with eligible
young women and he met this young woman
miner Miller who's from Akron Ohio now
the interesting thing about her is that
her father was Lois Miller the inventor
of the Reaper a variety of the Makah of
the Reaper sort of in the same
generation as the McCormick Reaper
it was a very successful businessman who
raised a large family in Akron lived in
a big house sent his children to the
best schools and miner was a very
self-possessed very talented very
beautiful young woman she was only 19
when he met her but she was much more
educated and I believe much more
self-possessed than his first wife and
it was a difference in mr. Edison's age
in his second wife's age let's see he
would have been in they were married in
1885 so he was in his 40s she was and
she was about 20 he's about twice her
age and they had how many children they
had three children Madeleine Charles and
Theodore the man I mentioned at the
beginning of this show the person that I
meant say that when he died Thomas
Edison died he had a state of 12 million
dollars indeed that was in the 1930s
mm-hmm mm-hmm would that have been like
today the only heavens the thing that
it's interesting about that the estate
of Thomas Edison is that there was a the
way the estate was was disposed in the
will is really a very instructive
metaphor for his relationship to his
children I mean what interested me about
the estate were the conditions of the
will insofar as the fact that the two
sons from the second marriage
Charles and Theodore were the major
beneficiaries and the three children
from the first marriage and the daughter
from the second marriage were sort of
given second-class citizenship in the in
the terms of that will you see the
relationship that Edison had with his
first wife of course conditioned the
problematic relationship that he had
especially with the children from the
first marriage and it really conditioned
a lot of the problems that they had
growing up a lot of the problems they
had relating to him as a father
that's something they never outgrow at
the height of his success who were his
best friends well the whole subject of
Edison's friendships is instructive too
because here you have a person who has
been become known in a kind of exclusive
way for the pantheon of of material
goods that we again mentioned earlier on
and yet when you start to look at the
structure of Edison's work you find out
that the other root of his genius was
his ability to hire the best people
people who stayed with him for decades
Charles Batchelor John Kruse II William
Kennedy Dixon Jonas Ellsworth Francis
Upton these are people that I I would
bet that those names don't ring true
with too many people watching this
program right now where as Thomas Edison
has become a household name but the
thing is that these employees had
expertise in electricity physics
chemistry and so forth and so on and
these were the people who were behind
the scenes making the tremendous
research and development contributions
to Edison's corpus of work and what
happened was when a time came and the
time came to file the patent their name
was put subsidiary to Edison's the the
patent was filed under Edison's auspices
they were given in most cases taken off
salary and given a percentage of the
gross revenues for these inventions in
perpetuity so the trade off for these
people was anonymity in the history
books
until recently until now and until the
whole you know the whole sort of Edison
scholarship that's grown up around him
in the last decade or so but College you
know education for their children
a house and a secure income you see so
when you ask about his friendships these
were very tight colleague relationships
that were predicated upon involvement in
these great inventions what was his
relationship to Harvey Firestone Henry
Ford John burrows rjh de l'eau yes well
there's a picture that you have later on
of course in the 1890s 1896 I believe
was when Edison met Henry Ford and
that's a different genre of friendship
because that has to do with an older man
by that time Edison being a revered icon
in in the mind of Henry Ford who at that
time was working for the Detroit Edison
Company he was actually an employee of
Edison's by extension at a certain
period and he was just Henry Ford was
just beginning to become involved in the
internal combustion engine and he went
to a convention of Edison managers in
Long Island at which Edison gave a
speech and someone brought forward over
to Edison's table and said here's a
young man who's began to work on the
internal combustion engine and he sat
down next to Edison and sketched on a
napkin his design for the stroke engine
he was working on an S and pounded his
hand on the table and said you know
you've got a good idea keep at it and
one day you know he'll become a success
there's a certain apocryphal strain to
that but the fact is that Henry Ford was
Thomas Edison's greatest admirer and
most long-standing admirer for all time
and at times when Edison was having
problems financially with his cash flow
Edison Ford would um would Commission
him for instance to design a battery for
the Model T and it gave him a loan of
two or three hundred thousand dollars to
to get get him through and and helps
support Edison at the end of his life
when he was doing his research in rubber
rubber the rubber plant but and just
peripherally as far as Burroughs and
Firestone were concerned there was a
whole series of camping trips that these
men went on during the teens and 20s
when they would take a caravan of cars
and go out into the mountains and sit
around the fire and talk about the great
issues of the day and of course always
wearing their white shirts and ties but
I wasn't exactly roughing it but they
were there was a sort of a male bonding
that went on there for a while between
these captains of industry he said that
Thomas Edison was a populist I did not
yeah I didn't use that word lightly I
think that if you look at some of these
statements he made about his the the
rationale behind some of his inventions
you will find statements sort of akin to
Henry Ford's I will build a car for the
great multitudes in the same way you
have Edison for instance I don't know
how familiar people are with Edison's
work with prefabricated housing for
working people Edison was convinced that
he could design a concrete house that
would be poured into a mold in one day
the entire house would be poured into a
cast-iron mold from the top and he would
he would he had a concept that he would
build huge housing developments very
cheaply for as he called it the working
man to allow him to provide the this
sort of American dream the American
ideal of the home the freestanding home
for his family and when he was producing
the phonograph records his main goal was
to promote music that was palatable to
the masses and that conformed to his
taste his poet his taste in literature
ran to poets such as Longfellow who was
his all-time face
right I mean he had a very mainstream
sensibility and he believed he was in a
position to disseminate that through his
Thomas Edison industries so that's why I
say populist this is a real leap fine I
can handle it
when we took a tour of the Ross Perot
little Museum outside of his office mmm
a couple years ago during the political
campaign one of his proud moments was to
stop and point to a letter that was
written by Thomas Edison and signed on
the wall why would that be that valuable
today you mean why would it why does it
seem that Ross Perot what value that
letter
I mean obviously it was an expensive
item I suspect I mean it did say how
much he paid as I think that there's a I
know I read an op-ed piece about Ross
Perot and and it referred to his his
reverence for Thomas Edison from from an
entrepreneurial standpoint which i think
is very easy to understand that there's
a certain sense of identity there with
the sensibility of Thomas Edison how
would Thomas Edison's inventions do
today in the governmental regulation we
have here
well you know there was a very apt
analogy during the First World War
Edison was was contracted briefly with
the Department of the Navy to develop
new technologies to help with submarine
warfare and he came to actually came to
Washington and lived here for about a
year working for the naval consulting
board as it was called at the time and
he developed a roster of three or four
dozen different inventions mostly having
to do with ways of tracking submarines
and sending up flares and signaling
other boats and he advocated you know a
certain type of naval commerce that
would avoid danger and so forth and so
on
unfortunately none of these none of
these ideas was adapted by the Navy and
Edison when
feeling very much disillusioned by the
bureaucracy at the time but he really
wanted to support his country it was a
real patriot this picture mm-hmm the
Navtech well you know the naps were
important to Edison the cat naps that
was taken in his lab at West Orange I
think that some of the stories that
we've all grown up with about Edison not
needing any sleep really they're looking
at I think a more accurate way of
describing it would be that he could he
could survive on five four or five hours
of sleep at night that's true because
his pattern was such that he'd like to
stay up late after everyone else went to
sleep
I'd be upstairs in his study and at that
time he had what was called a thought
bench up there which was a place where
he would sit when he was totally quiet
totally isolated so that he could
reflect and really distill his thinking
and sort out what he was gonna do the
next day and plan his whole next day
while the whole rest of the family was
asleep but during the day as an older
man he would get tired and he would have
to take these cat naps and he was known
for being able to fall asleep in the
most inhospitable circumstances he could
literally sleep anywhere and then he
would wake up refreshed after five or
six minutes did you get to know him you
think well enough that you could
describe what it would be like to spend
a couple of hours with I think I could
as a matter of fact of the of the three
subjects I've written about I think that
Edison would would have been the one
that I personally could have connected
with the best I think because of his
many many times stated appreciation of
the combination of imaginative thinking
and hard work and someone asked me the
other day you know where is the genius
reside is that reside in the imagination
or does it reside in the hard work and I
said I think it's a synthesis of both
that it's not a Eureka kind of thing
it's not a flash it's the understanding
that the tributaries of
our work feed into and out of the
creative mind and you cannot just expect
to have ideas spring fully formed out of
your mind from beginning to end they
require a consciously directed effort
and I think that that I believe there
would have been an intuitive
understanding of that dynamic in a human
being I think that I could have
communicated with Edison on that level
what did he end up dying of oh well he
ended up dying of is pretty much a
system breakdown you might say he had
congestion of the lungs
he had very serious digestive problems
as an older person as a matter of fact
the last couple of years of his life he
was on an all milk diet which of course
I you know I from a medical standpoint I
don't know what the rationale would be
except that he was various it's a very
sensitive to many foods and they
couldn't eat a lot of things and he lost
a lot of weight and became very weak and
it wasn't a question of his heart giving
out or his brain giving out it was
pretty much his his respiratory system
and his digestive system combined how
did you get interested in biography well
I think I'm a student of the human
condition I've always been interested in
in other words I think my interest in
biography is built upon my interest in
people in general and in in
understanding what motivates people just
people that I know people that I've
known throughout my whole life I think
really biography the craft of biography
is a sleuthing job that requires you to
like like a detective you know you have
to build all the evidence as we're
seeing nowadays you know you have to
build and collect all the evidence you
have to I always like to get all my
research together in one place before I
start writing you know I like to have my
entire case as it were laid out for me
from beginning to end before I start to
actually work on the book where do you
write the book
in my study on the third floor of my
house in a little room under the eaves
there with a computer I mean it's not
very romanticized but it's it's on the
third floor so the rest of the family
activities take place on the first and
second floors and I can be somewhat I
have to be somewhat I have to be
somewhat isolated to do the work but I I
mean the the fieldwork and the
collection of the data is what is what
is the social part that I also enjoy how
many places did you go for instance did
you go to the little home in Milan Ohio
yes I would like I would like to I'm
proud of the fact that I went to every
single place that Edison lived in this
country that is to say Milan Ohio Port
Huron Michigan Boston New York Newark
Menlo Park West Orange and then I went
to Florida where he had his major winter
estate which is in Fort Myers on the
Caloosahatchee River in Florida has a
beautiful home there which of course he
designed himself and landscaped himself
I also went to England because I did
research at the institution for
electrical engineers over there and they
have a whole archive from the time when
Thomas Edison electrified a ten square
block section of the city of London
which he did before in New York so
there's a whole sort of subtext of
Thomas Edison's residence over there in
London and his electrification of this
of the Center City of London the Holborn
viaduct area has his tradition been
captured at all these places are there
plaques are there Holmes other tours
they vary in they vary in complexity and
in degree of elaboration I mean the west
orange factory complex which is just
across from New York is is a
nineteenth-century
kind of Gothic structure with tours and
a shop and docents and so forth and then
his estate Glenmont is in Llewellyn Park
is up the hill from the factory so you
get a very good sense of his room
ship of his home life to his working
life the Fort Meyers site is a very
popular tourist attraction because it's
so picturesque it keeps it all going
well that again it's very different in
all the different places the the Fort
Meyers site is owned by the city of Fort
Myers whereas the the West Orange
Factory was given to the National Park
Service so it's part of the same system
that runs the OSEM 'ti and you know it's
part of the same system that runs the
outdoor parks that we are more familiar
with but it's run by the Park Service
the Mylyn little home little house is
run by the Historical Society they're
the Edison home Society in Port Huron
they're doing a very interesting
excavation an actual archeological
excavation of the site where Edison grew
up so you can stand on the hillside
overlooking the river where Edison stood
you can see the little train depot where
he worked as a child and it's right on
the river there what influence did
Thomas Paine have on his life huh well
Edison uh evidently as a young man read
the works of pain which were on the
bookshelf in his home in 1925 he
actually wrote a preface for a volume of
of pains writings and he felt a very
strong identification with pains
etiology as I talked about populism
earlier I think Edison felt that pain
was an exemplar of American values
especially of freedom of the individual
the autonomy of the individual which i
think was a major premise of Edison's
books you know obviously spent a lot of
time around books you've written through
yourself and you responsible for getting
that nice little book award announced
every year by the way what time of year
is it announced November right the week
before Thanksgiving is when we have our
big announcement of the winners and the
nominees the finalists are announced in
early October about six weeks before the
major event we have a dinner at the
Plaza which is sort of like the Oscars
and all the nominees
and we make a big hoopla about that and
that's when they were announced what do
they get the winners the winners well
each winner gets $10,000 and a bronze
statue by Joel Shapiro who actually is
the sculptor who did the statue at the
Holocaust Museum here
Joel Shapiro's the the artist who did
that statue and that he was commissioned
by the foundation to do uh a sort of a
bronze award that goes to each winner
and the finalists each get $1,000
are you precluded from entering
yeah Ward the Board of Trustees actually
just before just a few weeks ago the
board of trustees of the National Book
Foundation decided that obviously anyone
who's running the National Book Awards
can't be an entrant in the National Book
Awards how many people on your board we
have 15 trustees it's about half CEOs of
publishing companies because the
publishing industry has always had a
strong representation and then we have
other authors and as I say philanthropic
private citizens is there any point in
the process of choosing the book winners
of the year where you throw your hands
up and say there's too much politics in
this I really think that the National
Book Award because of the way we set up
the process unlike some other awards I
think the National Book Award has
maintained its democratic structure we
have different judges every year that
are that are an autonomous panel that
make their own deliberations and come to
their own conclusions
the publishers are only only the
publishers are allowed to submit the
titles and they're not allowed to submit
them with any accompanying material of
any kind and they're not allowed to
communicate directly with the judges at
all at any time because this shows
devoted to nonfiction who are back books
what's the future of that industry how's
it dying which which fiction books
well I think the future of I think the
future of quality American literature is
very good because I think publishers are
beginning to to understand that the
reading public is capable of reaching
for higher standards and I think you
have to look I think you you know you
have to look beyond the bestseller list
then I've been going into bookstores for
a long long time and I think that the
the independent bookstores and the
chains together are presenting more
titles buy more authors that are causing
the the reading public to reach a little
bit more to stretch a little bit more
and they can stretch and they will
having ideally put your soul a year and
is it going up well I can tell you this
about forty-five to fifty thousand
different titles are published in this
country every single year different
titles every single year but the book
industry is about a billion dollar
industry now somebody's got to be
spending that thought up or down it's
going up it's going up
consumerism of books is definitely going
up how many biographies of Edison had
been written well one of the first
things I did before really starting this
book was I read every single board that
ever been written about Thomas Edison
and it went in phases there was a big
burst of stuff right about the time that
he reached middle age and he was
becoming famous and there was another
burst in the 1920s when he was becoming
revered as a deity almost in American
culture but in the last 35 years which
is what I was sort of focusing on
they've only been two biographies that
that are of any note which I talk about
is having some strengths in some
weaknesses but I think mine is the most
balanced and the one that deals the most
with him as a human being as a person as
well as a myth
guest Neil Baldwin the book Edison
inventing the century and we thank you
for joining us thank you very much